Not only has Netflix been spearheading a massive
change in the Hollywood marketplace as a whole,
but the digital streaming service has also
built an original programming slate that's
challenging awards season norms and giving
some beleaguered actors another shot at thriving
in the fame game.
Here are some stars who've enjoyed a serious
second career wind thanks to Netflix.
Adam Sandler
It's no secret that Adam Sandler's filmography
is a divisive one.
Some of his earlier pics earned wide appreciation,
like Billy Madison, The Waterboy, and Big
Daddy.
Others were passion projects built for the
critical crowd, like Punch Drunk Love and
Funny People.
But some were liked by almost no one, and
since it's his commercial success that's carried
Sandler through decades of off-the-wall film
fare, that batch of box office bummers and
critical letdowns has become problematic for
Sandler.
"The price is wrong, bitch."
Consider the critically obliterated Jack and
Jill and his flopped dad comedy That's My
Boy.
Even his would-be smash Pixels failed to live
up to the hype, which proved, unmistakably,
that Sandler's signature schtick wasn't landing
quite as well as it used to.
But Netflix still had faith in the slapstick
comedian and provided him a platform for a
whopping eight movies that people are actually
watching.
As of April 2017, a half billion hours of
Sandler projects had been screened on the
site, between The Ridiculous 6, The Do-Over,
and Sandy Wexler.
With at least a handful of Sandler films left
to go on the site, there's no doubt he's a
company man for Netflix now.
Natasha Lyonne
In the '90s, Natasha Lyonne was a bona fide
movie star for a brief spell, with leading
roles in films like Slums of Beverly Hills
and American Pie.
Somewhere along the way of her gearing up
for the sequel she lost her traction in Tinseltown
and she started landing just bit parts in
TV shows and little-seen movies.
But Netflix's hit series Orange is the New
Black came along at just the right time for
her, as she was still a recognizable enough
face, and her talent hadn't budged an inch
in her absence from the spotlight.
In the series, she stars as the troubled inmate
Nicky Nichols, who vacillates between being
among the most earnest and intelligent members
of the Litchfield prison population to the
most damaged and uncontrollable of the lot.
It's a meaty role for Lyonne to delve into,
even if she doesn't appear in every single
episode, and she's started to pick up more
prestige work as a result of the series, like
a recurring role in Portlandia.
Ethan Embry
As a child star of the '80s, Ethan Embry was
an absolute hit-maker with feel-good holiday
favorites like Dutch and All I Want for Christmas.
Even his teen years were kind to his career,
with his memorable supporting roles in Empire
Records, That Thing You Do!, and Can't Hardly
Wait.
But somewhere around the turn of the millennium,
Embry's star status started to significantly
fade.
He still did enough work to keep the lights
on, of course, but the caliber of films and
TV shows he was earning placement in was a
far cry from the mainstream movie scene he'd
grown up in.
His recurring role in Netflix's Gracie & Frankie,
however, seems to be turning the tide.
Not only is it the first truly regular TV
role he'd had in a decade, but it's given
him a chance to fully break away from that
wholesome, cherubic boy image he'd been associated
with for so long.
"What do you mean it's looking good.
That's great!
We did it.
Give me high five!"
Brit Marling
This Chicago native has had more than her
fair share of splashy screen moments in her
still-young career.
Count Another Earth and Sound of My Voice
among her buzziest projects.
But Brit Marling has still had trouble establishing
herself as a leading star, despite noteworthy
attempts on the indie circuit, until Netflix
came along and gave her fever dream project,
The OA, a chance.
Overnight, she went from that woman you might
seen in the background of that one movie to
a completely compelling show creator and lead
star whose continued work on the series was
heavily in demand for a second season, and
whose future project ideas are undoubtedly
going to get the top-of-the-pile treatment
from here on out.
Rosario Dawson
It may be hard to believe that Rosario Dawson's
career ever needed a shot in the arm.
But after the actress hit it big with films
like Men in Black II, Seven Pounds, and Sin
City, casting directors appeared to cool on
the actress for several years before she nabbed
a prime place in the Marvel-Netflix show universe,
starting with Daredevil in 2015.
She's since reprised her role as Claire Temple
through almost all of the sister properties
and appears to be recapturing her mainstream
momentum even outside of the MCU with parts
in The LEGO Batman Movie and X-Men: The New
Mutants.
Deborah Ann Woll
True Blood fans were widely taken by then-newcomer
Deborah Ann Woll's vexing screen presence,
but she's had a hard time establishing herself
outside of Bon Temps ever since that HBO series
came to an end.
Thanks to a series of straight-to-DVD fare,
it seemed like Woll might not ever find her
niche outside of the fang-banging scene.
Luckily, she earned a spot in Netflix's Daredevil
adaptation just in the nick of time, and now
she's spanning the Netflix-MCU series, with
her character Karen Page appearing in The
Punisher and The Defenders.
Winona Ryder
For over a decade, Winona Ryder had reached
icon status in Hollywood thanks to her unforgettable
on-screen presence in films like Edward Scissorhands,
Beetlejuice, and Girl, Interrupted.
But her reputation went very south in 2001
when she was caught shoplifting from a department
store.
She had a great deal of trouble reaching the
A-list again after that, even despite some
notable performances in films like Black Swan
and The Iceman.
But Netflix's Stranger Things has put her
right back on the map with her delightfully
off-kilter turn as Joyce Byers, the mother
of a boy who's been kidnapped by a toothy
monster.
She's still seen as a little bit of a kook,
especially after her ultra-memeable appearance
at the SAG Awards, but thanks to Netflix she's
in the news for her acting again, instead
of her legal troubles.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!